no se me ocurre una mejor manera para
dar la bienvenida a nuestra directora
económica Daniela Blandón que además de
ser una grandísima periodista Es una
excelente bienvenida Dani Muchas gracias
Juan me parece que he escuchado esa
canción en algún lado en alguna parte la
hemos escuchado vamos a cambiar del
reggaeton del perreo a la economía
porque hay noticia con la mayor empresa
de vapeadores de Estados Unidos que
acordó millonarias indemnizaciones
estamos hablando de esta compañía que
acordó pagar 462 millones de dólares a
los estados de Nueva York California
Illinois Massachusetts Nuevo México y
Colorado y también al distrito de
Columbia todo eso para resolver los
cargos de que violó numerosas leyes en
la comercialización de productos de
tabaco para jóvenes antes ya había
cortado pagar una suma similar a 34
estados escuchamos
a los consumidores sobre el riesgo para
la salud de sus productos la compañía de
cigarrillos electrónicos les hizo creer
falsamente que temporizadores eran más
seguros que los cigarrillos y contenían
menos nicotina sin embargo sobre una
cápsula de Yule contiene tanta nicotina
como un paquete completo de cigarrillos
Juan y las autoridades creen que el uso
de cigarrillos electrónicos entre
estudiantes de secundaria y de
preparatoria se duplicó con creces
después de que esta marca se introdujo
por primera vez en 2015 nos quedamos en
la Unión Americana con una de las
noticias del día porque la inflación
parece que se está moderando pues su
variación interanual fue del 5% en marzo
un punto menos que en febrero casi la
mitad del pico que alcanzó A mediados
del año pasado también es la variación
más baja desde mayo de 2021 y hay que
decir que los precios de la energía
bajaron y los de los alimentos siguieron
al alza mientras que la inflación
subyacente que es la que excluye estos
ítems anteriores por ser más volátiles
sigue subiendo impulsada por la vivienda
Dani justo decidieron a conocer detalles
de la más reciente reunión de la reserva
Federal de qué se trata Pues en el
documento conocido como las minutas de
la Fed en la que reconocen que el
colapso de algunos bancos pequeños los
hizo moderarse en su más reciente alza
de intereses Pues también dicen que no
descartan las posibilidades de que este
año ya una pequeña recesión precisamente
por este motivo vamos a cambiar de tema
porque ahí nos dice con enviar la
emisora pública de Estados Unidos que va
a dejar de publicar en Twitter La
historia comenzó la semana pasada cuando
la red social de elon musk que etiquetó
la cuenta principal de enviar o la
National public radio como medio
afiliado al Estado un término que
también se usa para identificar a los
controlados o fuertemente influenciados
por gobiernos autoritarios como Rusia y
China ahora cambió esa clasificación por
medio de comunicación de origen de
gubernamental pero para emplear ese
engañoso porque su financiación depende
en menos del 1% del gobierno y y por eso
acusa a la empresa de querer socavar su
credibilidad la cadena de televisión
pública public broadcasting service y
hizo lo mismo y la bbc de Londres
también se ha quejado por esta nueva
distinción Cómo se definen precisamente
Dani a esos medios afiliados al gobierno
en esa etiqueta que vemos en Twitter
pues One Twitter las define como medios
donde el estado
ejerce el contenido editorial
medinancieros o presiones políticas
directas o indirectas Aunque aclara que
las que cumplen con esta condición pero
que tienen Independencia editorial Como
por ejemplo la bbc en Reino Unido o
Enviar no entran en la categoría de
medios afiliados al Estado de todas
maneras eso no les gusta tengo muy
polémico Y de nuevo seguimos hablando de
Twitter y de y lo más un día más Dani un
gigante de la industria de lujo
mostró muy buenos resultados
esta semana los a la revelación de
resultados de las grandes compañías
listadas en bolsa hoy el turno es para
Louis vuitto quien también es
propietaria de la casa de moda dior así
como del coñal Génesis y la joyería
estadounidense Tiffany sus ventas
superaron los 20 mil millones de dólares
crecieron más del 17% frente a los tres
primeros meses del año pasado este líder
de la industria de la alta gama atribuye
el resultado a China que le está
ayudando a compensar a los
estadounidenses que están comprando
menos el gigante asiático en rescate de
la Industria de la moda momento de ir
con la cifra del día qué le va a gustar
porque se trata de cine 0,8 peniques de
libra esterlina ni siquiera una libra
esterlina cuesta hoy una acción de la
británica cineworld Esta es la segunda
cadena de cines más grande del mundo que
fracasó en su intento de vender sus
negocios en Reino Unido Estados Unidos e
Irlanda y que acaba de acogerse a un
proceso de reorganización que amenaza
con borrar de un plumazo la inversión de
sus socios en la bolsa sus acciones hoy
rompieron un nuevo mínimo histórico en
el mercado de Londres y han caído un 99%
desde 2007 bueno
las noticias para el cine Dani
Muchísimas gracias por haber estado con
nosotros pues le tengo para cerrar una
noticia bursátil que también le va a
gustar Warner Bros Discovery estrenará
el 23 de mayo su servicio de streaming
el llamado Max en Estados Unidos Esta es
una fusión entre hbo Max y Discovery más
mientras haya menos plataformas mejor Yo
creo para los bolsillos de todos
nosotros Dani Muchísimas gracias
nosotros continuamos aquí en directo
América